okay et this is it this is the uh year
five show number 113 on blossom
and it's called goodbye which is fitting
because this is our farewell show
so my name is joey lawrence and uh i'm
gonna take you behind the scenes on this
very last show this very
special show to all of us here who have
worked on blossom for five long years
and you guys are going to have an inside
look at how everyone's feeling and
all the emotions that are flying around
this very last day
well i guess here's where it all
happened this is the uh
blossom set this is blossom's bedroom
actually and
mime and i have had some great scenes in
this room uh
ever since gosh ever since i was 13 and
a half years old so
a lot of memories in that room and i'm
sorry to see it go but
this is where it all started is in this
bedroom right there just say what's on
your mind
that is whatever tiny part of your mind
isn't on half-naked women
here's a little behind-the-scenes look
right there at our infamous porch where
many a times joey russo's kissed his
girlfriends and blossoms kissed her
boyfriends
several scenes that happened in several
scenes right there under the
moonlight which is actually a light with
a blue filter
this is the infamous living room set and
uh
i think some of our greatest scenes have
happened right right in this room this
is where
um everybody really came of age i think
and all of our problems were
dealt with so um a lot of things have
happened monumental events this is where
we had both
both weddings on the show so far
happened right in this room
with uh nick and uh uh finola and uh
tony and his and so and samaria michael
and samaria so
this is where a lot of things happen and
uh i don't know such a beautiful room
this is the kitchen this is the kitchen
and if i'm not mistaken i think this is
the first
this is one of this is the first room
actually in the very first pilot
that we ever did for this show this is
the kitchen cause the first scene took
place in this very room
have you ever heard of something called
tough love dad i swear those are my
magazines vinnie hit him under my bed
this is just the back porch this is
where uh
joey russo and blossom used to sneak in
a lot if they used to stay out late and
usually get caught because uh it is tv
so you know we would get caught
this is where we have intros five and a
half years this is where we've walked up
these stairs
every single night this is the infamous
wall of gum if you guys can imagine this
we've been working on this for five
years
actually three because we had the first
two seasons they
revamped the set and they took down our
wall and we were very sad but
we built it back and here here it is
this is everyone's guns we always chew
gum
a little nervous energy before the show
and uh rather than
throw it away we just used to stick it
up here so we have a bunch of things
this is about 45 billion pieces of gum
right here
hey mario what's up how you doing
you doing all right okay all right now
if everybody's watching you guys all
know who this is this is blasphemy the
reason why this whole
show existed so uh is there anything
that you
that you'd like to say i'm gonna take my
rollers in you wanna say anything about
what it's been like for five years
to work with me well just what we were
talking about before i know i remember
when
you were like 13 when we started and it
was
so weird just that we were so young i
think it's sunken in i mean
i kind of expected it i just kind of had
a feeling that this was going to be our
last year so i guess it's kind of sunken
in but
i think it's all going to happen i mean
once they said okay we're done with
rehearsal get ready for show it was
weird and we just kind of sat there and
it was strange and i think you know in
all the scenes all the things that joey
and i say to each other are true
you know that all these things happen
that we're gonna carry with us till we
die and it all happened like right here
okay et well that's it uh that's the end
of our run and i want to thank you guys
for being here with us
today and um stay tuned and check us out
in syndication all right all right
thanks a lot we'll see you guys later
[Music]
you